[Music]
we're playing somebody same rating as me
okay let's go e4
all right
a6 that is new i think we've faced this
a couple of times before in the speedrun
the question is is this a troll
now a6b5 is believe it or not a pretty
legitimate opening it's known as the
saint george's defense and it's
important for white to it's important
for us to position our pieces correctly
which is actually believe it or not not
as trivial as it may seem
so the setup that i like to play against
a6
is knight on f3
bishop on d3 and then the knight on b1
doesn't go out to c3 until later in fact
we often put a pawn on c3 you guys know
that i i quite like that setup in
general
when we go knight f3 bishop b7 is
of course the main move for black okay
d6 is
i mean i guess is possible doesn't
really change our approach i think his
standard average
and this bishop comes out to d3 why d3
so that it reinforces the e4 pawn so
that if blackfin ketos we don't really
have to worry about this pawn becoming
weak
right
now
what can you tell me about this b5 pawn
is there any way that we could punish
black
for
essentially playing a6 b5 let's start by
castling by the way let's let's get
castling out of the way first this idea
isn't going anywhere yeah we can
and this is a positional idea that i
think everybody over 1200 should be
familiar with you know whenever there's
pawns on a6 and b5
we we have the possibility of going a4
and we can even do it here we don't have
to develop all of our pieces for this to
be effective
and essentially this challenge is the
pawn of b5 and c6 is a very typical
mistake that's already a blunder and i'm
sure that you guys see why there's an
x-ray going on here
so we can play a takes b5 c takes b5 and
then bishop takes b5 check the rook on
a8 is undefended so we went upon a5 oh
this is looking very very ugly for black
okay i mean we have multiple ways we can
handle this we can just leave the pawn
on b5 but for the sake of simplicity i
propose just taking on c6
and uh in response to knight takes c6
i'm positive that some of you are
probably tempted by bishop b5
but remember you know always try to
evaluate pins for their long-term
benefit don't just make a move because
it looks good this should be five black
plays bishop d7
and we haven't really achieved anything
so what move do i like to play in such
positions
knight and the bishop are both attacking
only one thing
so
it doesn't really make sense to go d5
because that expands the diagonal for
the bishop that justifies black's play
justifies black's play by expanding the
diagonal and giving the knight extra
squares
not bishop e3
but rather we play c3
biting on granite this is one of my
favorite pawn constructions now look at
how inefficient the bishop and the
knight are
and now we can complete our development
so i propose getting this bishop out
before we get the night out we can play
bishop e3
we can also play bishop g5 just to
prevent him from pushing his
epon uh him or her from pushing their
epon and knight f6 knight bd2 we've
completed our development
there is one more move that i would like
to make
you know which is part of the general
rubric of completing our development
what am i talking about this is a move
that
you know you just often play in many
different types of positions
it's too early for e5 let's not
bother ourselves with these kinds of
moves
yeah we can play h3 but the move i was
actually talking about is rookie one
it's just a good idea in these positions
because a lot of you are probably
noticing that
the possibility of going e45 is very
much
uh very much something we should be
considering
and the other thing we we have time to
do is is to make some love let's go h3
and the reason i'm not hesitating about
these moves is just because we're up
upon we're incredibly solid
we can afford such positional niceties
right we can afford to make these
improving moves without really even a
second thought
and
now that we've improved our position
essentially to the maximum
you know now we can start thinking about
taking more concrete steps to convert
our extra pawn in our excellent position
so multiple ways of doing that but we've
already been discussing the e5 pawn
break
now if you play e5 right here then black
takes with the pawn
and if you take back with the pawn
remember that when you push upon an
attack and now you often relinquish your
control over a certain square
in this case the knight can hop back
into d5
not too
enthralled that concept so what i like
doing here is going knight c4 i like the
concept of knight c4 now after e5 d
takes c5 we're gonna take back with the
knight and if black takes with the
knight then we take with the other
knight and we're just gonna have an
absolute monster
sitting on e5 attacking f7
so i much prefer to recapture e5 of the
knight does that make sense now if black
tries to beat us to the punch then
notice that the d6 pawn is going to hang
okay rook b8
do we need to do anything about that
well let's calculate the rook now stares
down to b2 pawn
um can we play e5 so e5 d e knight f
takes e5
knight takes c5 knight takes e5
yeah we can play it because rook takes
b2 walks into knight takes f7 remember
that the spawn is now a forkable square
so the time has come for us to go e5
we don't need to get our queen into the
game yet right this is
misconception i've talked about doesn't
matter which knight we take with let's
take with this knight just because this
knight on c4 hits on the a5 if iphone it
defends b2
uh common misconception yet again that
we need every single piece in the game
before we open up the center for example
no
we'll get the queen into the game when
the time comes but right now the
services of the queen are not not needed
the pieces are doing a perfectly fine
job handling the situation without the
queen okay so 95 95
and now we're threatening f7
so b2 is untouchable
and notice also i was about to say
bishop e6 is very very likely and in
such situations you have a knight in the
center what do i always tell you to do
look at potential forks right don't just
stop at one fork
look at all potential forks but there's
a very interesting subtlety here that we
need to factor into account this is
probably not going to be needed but
let's play accurately
what do i see here well i'm noticing a
slightly disturbing thing the bishop on
g5 is an undefended piece
okay well what difference does that make
well it makes a very specific difference
after knight c6 black actually has quite
an unpleasant defensive response what am
i talking about queen d5
now you might say well that how does
that help we just take the rook well if
you take the rook then black's queen
captures our bishop on g5 now do you see
why that could lead to a problem
it's still winning for white but you
should see that the knight on b8 is
going to be hanging and what else is
black threatening in that position who
can tell me who can tell me what else
black is threatening after knight c6
queen d5 knight takes b8 queen takes g5
yeah black is threatening bishop takes
h3 now is there a way for us
not to allow that well what do i even
mean by that the first place you should
look is at the start right maybe we can
make a different move at the start in
order to take away that possibility
entirely and we can we can take the
knight on f6 that's pretty elementary my
dear watson then we play knight c6
knight takes b8 there's no bishop to
attack on g5 we'll speed up just a
little bit here
under four minutes okay so he did go
queen d5 and
this paid off tremendously
okay now we should defend b2
and you know now finally we can do with
the queen our queen is currently not
doing anything let's put it e2 c2 d2 it
doesn't matter okay it really doesn't
matter let's put it on e2 let's put it
toward the center
now we're up in exchange and upon this
is completely winning the rest is a
matter of pretty simple technique but
i'll try my best to be accurate
here okay so what how am i thinking of
converting this well
first things first i
i would love to trade one pair of
bishops just to eliminate black's only
trump card which is his two bishops
so that's that's
one thing i would consider
okay the other thing that i that i
notice here is that the a5 pawn is a
pretty significant weakness it always
has been
and currently it's only protected by the
queen so what move immediately comes to
mind right just by that observation
alone you should already consider
this move
yeah bishop c4 kind of wins upon it also
skewers the f7 pawn by the way so which
we might very well take okay so
bishop f7 our opponent is defending
quite resiliently i have to say bishop
takes h3
so we have a nice move here
um
i don't like queen f3 because it drops
the b2 pawn i don't really like queen f3
but we can amend that idea slightly and
rather than playing queen after we can
play the move queen e3
important idea folks queen e3
which poses black with an ultimatum
either he declines the queen trait
and gives us another tempo which we
could use to bring the rook up to e2
or
or black takes on b2 but that means
allowing a queen trade which is totally
unthinkable you have to realize that the
queen queen trade is worth the price of
the pawn
now there is an even better way of
defending the pun rookie 2 still creates
a situation where our rook is a little
bit passive the move i prefer is pawn b3
now we have a completely self-sufficient
situation here we don't have to worry
about this with any other of our pieces
and our rooks and our queens are you
know have wiped their hands of the task
of defending b2 and can focus on more
important things
such as attacking a5 which incidentally
now is even more fixed than it was
before
now we're threatening to take on f7 here
which i absolutely will if given the
opportunity
okay rook f8 we are not given the
opportunity
okay well instead i think we will take
this opportunity to
start surrounding the
uh the the a5 a5 pawn how are we going
to do that well we're going to double
rooks on the a file that is the most
traditional method
of attacking a pawn that sits on an open
file right
pretty simple stuff
incidentally we could also bring this a
rook over to the e file if necessary if
the situation demands it it's not like
our rooks
you know are banished to siberia right
that's an important thing to understand
as well okay this move doesn't really do
anything concrete it stares at the g2
pawn it's important to notice that but
it's also important not to be afraid of
ghosts and
this doesn't threaten anything at all we
can proceed with our plan
we also could have played the move d5
which intercepts
the queen of the bishop okay bishop g5
what is the best response to this move
let's play accurately don't just move
your queen back as an instinct really
take a couple of seconds and really see
where the queen should go what is the
nicest square
yeah queen e5 check is great
because it's a check
and if black plays f6 he drops e7 with
tempo
if black moves the king then obviously
we have now time to take on a5 so this
is where playing just marginally more
precisely is going to get you a lot of
points because you're not going to lose
on time
um and and you're just not going to
spend as much time messing around
if at the start you play more accurately
now we trade queens
we're gonna take on a5 and it's a
totally winning position
of course we'll trade yeah now here
we're up three pawns so it makes much
more sense to trade than to not trade
okay and here our strategy is quite
simple we want to trade as much as we
can
now how i would think of this position
is
i want to play rook a8 ideally i want to
play rook 8 now we can't because there's
a bishop on c6
okay well you might say well does that
mean we should play d5 well there is an
even better move than d5 we can kill two
birds with one son we can try to get
this bishop off of this diagonal
while also offering another trade
bishop d5 bishop d5 is just a buzz saw
buzzkill
all right because either the bishops are
traded and then black is out of
resources to contain our passers
or
the bishop moves away and then we go
rook a8 and it's the same thing happens
just
with a different trade
yeah this is completely resignable and
we've got plenty of time to win this
okay now the strategy is very simple
we are going to use the b-pawn and we're
going to promote it and we're going to
force black to give up a bishop for that
pawn
but let's not rush um first we should
activate our pieces to the maximum
what move does that entail
this move is going to make it a lot
easier for us to push the pawn
rook eight eight oh okay seven yeah get
the rook to the seventh ring hit the
bishop
always a safe bet
now we've got
both of our pieces on great squares
let's start pushing b4
and this is a very easy
matter of now here generally uh
defending this square would be what
piece should be doing that right should
we go rook b7 or is there a better way
to do that
there is a better way to do that bishop
c6 rolling out the red carpet b5 b6 etc
and i'm expecting e6
with the idea of b5 bishop d8 nope it's
just going to let us play b5 fine
have it your way
don't worry the time is we've got more
than enough time to win this
five times over
and
black is not even really making an
attempt to stop the bond
okay
summon
okay bishop d2 is not even i was going
to say a mouse slip but it's but it's
not it just lets us
promote this would be winning with
five seconds on the clock
now
rook takes c7 is possible but if you
want to be totally clinical what's the
most accurate move here what's the move
that just like
what is the
the like kasparov move here
not rook a8 guys now get your queen to
the center right get your queen to the
center queen e5 check to me queen e5
check looks like the fastest path to
checkmate because it
we're talking about semantics here but
it restricts the bishops and and it sort
of just prepares to get just get all of
your pieces to
mating squares i don't know how to
describe it
then we can take e7 and go queen f6
if the king drops back to h6
i think a lot of people have actually
have trouble charlie had a lot of
trouble with this you know delivering
checkmate once you've got a billion
extra pieces so
i'm kind of joking but i'm also not
joking and
you know it's worth paying attention to
how i'm doing this queen f6 check
and then after king h5 bishop f3
is checkmate in two g4 should take g4
goodbye let's stick with the pawn just
for the sink of aesthetics
okay so a6
obviously not not the greatest opening
in the universe but also far from the
worst
of all of the corner pawn moves a6 is
undoubtedly the best pushing the h fun i
think is is incomparably worse h6 g5
uh the mirror line on the other side of
the board is basically losing because it
creates too many king side weaknesses
so
yeah the setup i like is knight f3 and
generally black plays bishop b7 bishop
d3 e6 this is the main line actually
and i guess you could check
what uh you know what people recommend
on youtube i'm sure there are tutorial
videos
yeah now castles
black generally plays c5 and i like this
setup the sort of allopin-esque
setup with pawns on c3 and d4 and e4 you
know
this kind of aesthetic i like
very hard for black to do anything
in regards to our center does that make
sense
and and the way that you expand your
thinking here is as you depart from
beginner level you have to understand to
be start becoming more flexible
with peace development right
don't marry yourself to the idea of
putting knights on c3 and f3 every
single game understand that the knight
on d2 can be just as effective
so i won't delve too too far into the
theoretical discussion here d6 bishop d3
we played anyway
and a4 very important positional idea
now how should we respond in the event
of b4
what should we do here and there are
several ways that we could
play this but there is one move i like
to play in such positions
which is to prevent black from playing
a5
yeah so one way we can do this is go c3
c3 is a great move here
and in the event of the trade
who does the opening of the b file favor
well it favors the more active the
player with the more active pieces right
it's white we have an easier job getting
a rook to the b file than black does
but i also like the move a5 here which
prevents black from playing a5 and if
black plays c5 i mean he really
overextends himself in this position he
has this diagonal as we can kind of see
that this is very very flimsy now the
pawn on a6 is also kind of a long-term
weakness it's being stared at by the
bishop
okay
so i don't again not to delve too deeply
into this but just remember this concept
of a4 when black has pawns on a6 and b5
and of course vice versa
um
c6 is just a blunder a takes b5 and of
course the point is bishop takes b5
check and
uh because of the x-ray
black like a screw you can't take back
but um a5 is exacerbates the issue even
further because it just creates another
weakness
and at this point already it's a very
difficult position for black pawn down
weak pawn on a5 it's very very difficult
to defend such positions
excelsior yeah i guess
anyways
rookie one everything we did here should
be completely clear to literally
everybody i mean
if you have any questions about
why we played the way we did here feel
free but hopefully it was pretty clear
yeah now knight c4 right preparing e5
but in the right way this is a good
thing to think about if you have a pawn
break think about what it is that you
want to recapture with
right what piece do you ultimately want
to end up on e5 right is it the pawn is
it the rook well it's def
usually the answer to that question when
in doubt it's the knight his knights in
the center are you know in terms of
pieces that are centralized knights
get the most return on investment when
they're centralized versus other pieces
that's why we go knight c4
e5
and this is a terrible position for
black he's already almost lost
more resilient would have been to play
rook f8 obviously not
missing the fork
but uh we would have gone bishop c4
quite possibly and this puts more
pressure on f7 that's a terrible
position for black terrible
bishop b6 the only important tactical
moment in this game was bishop takes f6
just a subtlety right
and a lot of people would automatically
play knight c6 but training yourself to
pay attention to on defended pieces and
by the way bishop takes f6 now it's too
late for that because black can now take
the knight
um but training yourself to pay
attention to undefended pieces at all
times
and and not rushing into tempting moves
i mean that's really all that it takes
right because once i alerted you to the
fact that black had resource here
everybody saw queen d5
and once i told you
don't play knight c6 automatically you
guys saw this idea
uh but
that you know that's the you have to
remember to train yourself to do that
yourself
okay bishop f6 bishop f6 knight c6
and um
the rest of the game is
i think quite clear without analysis
queen e3 is a nice move defending h3
offering the queen trade weaponized
queen trade right using the queen trade
as a weapon to force your your
opponent's queen off of a good square
and then doubling on the a file hitting
and targeting the biggest weakness
um
muller i saw your question the first
time but unfortunately that's an
impossible question for me to answer
because it is two
questions of this nature until which elo
is this decisive that decisive it's
extremely relative losing a pawn is not
a monolithic concept ha being upon down
in a pawn end game
is completely different from losing a
pawn in the opening right and losing a
pawn in this opening is completely
different from losing a pawn in another
opening so like it's an unanswerable
question
uh because it really depends on where
the circumstances in which you lose upon
but if you know if i have to give you a
ballpark really under 1500 you shouldn't
worry too much about losing a pawn i
would say once you've hit 2000 that's
when losing a pawn kind of becomes a
disaster and at my level losing a pawn
can just be instantly decisive
but even at my level you know you can
lose upon and recover it's not like gm's
convert every pawn up position not even
every piece up position is converted by
gm's
i mean famously bronstein and batman
played a world championship match where
bronstein won a rook
and failed to convert it so
it's not like gm's are immune from
difficulty converting positions
and i don't think of it that way like oh
you hit this level and then you're never
going to have trouble with
any of this ever again
it's not how it works
david bronstein by the way great player
probably not as familiar of a name to
most people in the chat
so this position occurred on the board
um
bot vinegar has just gotten knight a4
bronstein drops his bishop back to a7
blundering a very nice tactic b6
bishop takes a4
b7
look at this
and it's over bishop takes b3 you make a
new queen
white is currently up in exchange and
both bishops are hanging at the same
time
it's a complete completely winning
position
um and bronstein said i became terribly
angry with myself and instead of
resigning the game
which is what the auditorium
buzzing like a beehive was expecting i
gathered my nerves into a single ball
and began quickly moving the remaining
pieces as though nothing had happened
someone turned out that one one of the
players was full of energy and was eager
for a battle to the death while the
other had demobilized his will and was
indifferently awaiting his opponent's
resignation that's a great quote
the subsequent course of the game showed
just how important the psychological
state of a chess player is after all the
man with his weaknesses is the main
thing in chess the rest being merely
pitiful attachments i don't know what
that means i'd have to read the original
queen b5
and bronstein just like activates his
pieces let's flip the board
the queen ia8 is is
not trapped black can't really trap it
because it's got a it's got several
escape routes but it currently can't
untrap itself on its own so bob any kind
of panics right the simple castle short
would have won the game
black just has one try
white tucks the king away on h1 and this
is
this is game over because it's only a
matter of time before white extricates
the queen
but dominick decides to give up an
exchange in order to get his queen out
of the game
and he ends up also giving up the pawn
on d5 and then he offers a queen trade
but he gives up another pawn to trade
queens and now bronstein has built up a
pretty impressive
uh little pawn phalanx in the center
white is still winning obviously on two
pawns for the piece only but bobinick
failed to convert the send game i mean
it's a very interesting end game
ultimately bronstein just completely
outplayed him you just made a lot more
progress than white and at some point
bob nick even had losing chances
and and here botvinnik offered to draw
in this completely unclear position
where even bronstein can try to play for
a win
you know and this is not
this is one of a million of such
examples that i could show you
and once we traded queens yeah the only
other thing bishop d5 right again
weaponizing the trade
posing a completely devastating i guess
ultimatum
i'm not sure what you're referring to
kavita
you mean taking blacks knight like this
line where we took the knight on f6
like why the immediate knight c6 wasn't
a good idea
yeah so here black has queen d5
and first of all if you say okay now
i'll take on f6
and then i'll take the rook no that
doesn't work anymore because black
doesn't have to take the bishop black
can take the knight and obviously the
king defends the bishop and white white
is still better we're up a pawn but not
more than that right number one
number two if you take on b8
black takes on g5 and the problem is
that the knight hangs
and because of this x-ray i'm sure you
see that bishop takes h3 is a pretty
nasty threat here now it's not the end
of the world but another thing that
hurts white is that if you move the
knight back to c6 again the knight is
undefended so instead of bishop takes h3
black can even play bishop d5 even
better
and this wins the night because of the
mate threat
simultaneous with the threat of taking
the knight right see what i'm saying
so it's just annoying it's just very
very annoying
so you would have to play knight a6
presumably
and then you'd have to deal with bishop
takes h3 and it's a whole hassle
all right guys i'll see you tomorrow bye
everybody
[Music]
you